Have you
ever heard the argument that the apostles of Jesus all died brutal deaths, being
stabbed to death, skinned alive, crucified, and therefore they didn't make up the
resurrection, and Christianity must be true?
I heard an argument quite similar to this growing up and found it quite compelling.
But recently I decided to dig deeper and examine the historical evidence that the
apostles actually died as martyrs.
What I found was not only surprising, but quite powerful.
Here are five key points of what I found.
The first point to understand is what is meant by an apostle.
When we look at the beginning chapters of Acts, we see that the disciples are coming
up with a replacement because of Judas who had betrayed Jesus.
And there's two criteria that they utilize.
One, the replacement had to have been with Jesus since his baptism by John the
Baptist. And second, the replacement to be in the twelve had to be an eyewitness of
the risen Jesus. The second point is to understand that the earliest message that
the Apostles preached was that Jesus had risen from the grave.
From the letters of Paul to the book of Acts where we see the first Christians going
out and building the church, the message that they gave was always tied
to the resurrection. There is no early Christianity apart from the belief that Jesus
rose from the grave. The third point is that the apostles preached a message
in direct opposition to the Roman state.
When the apostles stood up and said that Jesus is God, they were essentially saying
that Caesar is not. they were proclaiming that a criminal against the Roman state
was the risen Lord. They preached a message that made them enemies of the Roman
state.
And the fourth point is that the Apostles would not stop preaching the risen Jesus
even when they were threatened, beaten and thrown in prison.
If you look at the beginning of the book of Acts they're told by the religious
leaders just stop proclaiming that Jesus is Lord and will leave you alone, but they
refuse. They refuse to stop saying that Jesus has risen from the grave.
In fact in Acts chapter 5 Peter stands up when they're being threatened and he
speaks on behalf of the Apostles.
He says we can't. We must obey God rather than men.
Regardless of whether we accept some of the later grisly apocryphal accounts about
the deaths of the apostles what we know for sure is that all the apostles were
willing to suffer and die for their belief that jesus had conquered the grave
and the fifth point is that there is good historical evidence that at least some
of the apostles actually died as martyrs take james the brother of jesus
for example there's an account from josephus a jewish writer at the end of the first
century take James the brother of John there's an evidence a recording of his death
in Acts 12:2 at the hands of Herod and there are multiple pieces of evidence
different documents pointing out from the first and second century that both Peter
and Paul died as martyrs and there is no evidence that any of the Apostles
recanted their beliefs.
Wait right here.
You might be thinking, wait a minute.
What about all the other people throughout history who've been willing to die for
their beliefs? In fact, what about modern-day Muslim terrorists who died for their
faith? Does that mean Islam is true?
Yet here's an important distinction to keep in mind.
They weren't eyewitnesses of Muhammad doing miracles or allegedly receiving the
Quran. At best, they received their convictions fourth, fifth or sixth hand
from somebody else. Their deaths provide no more evidence for the truth of Islam
than my own death if I died as a martyr would provide evidence for Christianity.
But the apostles were eyewitnesses.
They saw the risen Jesus with their own eyes.
So if we conclude that they made it up, we'd have to say that they died for
something that they knew was false.
and that's difficult to believe.
This alone doesn't prove that Christianity is true, but it does show the depth of
the sincerity of the Apostles. They weren't making this story up.
They weren't liars. This wasn't a big conspiracy.
They were willing to suffer and die for their belief that Jesus had risen from the grave.
I wonder what else could the Apostles have done to convince us of the depth of
the sincerity of their beliefs.